a case I made was I can't change what
happened to you in the past but together
we may be able to help protect other
people
the truth basically their Pulitzer
prize-winning journalism brought down
one of Hollywood's most influential
producers and spurred a global Reckoning
on the sexual abuse of women
when Harvey Weinstein heard an article
was coming he allegedly said the story
sounds so good I want to buy the movie
rights now Behind Bars he'll take no
glory for this film Kerry Mulligan
thrilled to be playing one of the
journalists who broke the story and
thrilled to meet them
it was Rockstar cross stuff for us as
well I was hugely intimidated but not
that they're intimidating people that
couldn't be more lovely but they they
are just so impressive Harvest just
disputed Landing 8-12 shot in the actual
New York Times Newsroom with the pace of
a thriller it follows Megan Tui and Jody
cantor's attempts to persuade scared
sources to go on the record one of the
messages of this story especially as
time recedes is that the number of
people who really gave us publishable
information about Harvey Weinstein was
so small in the end we're talking about
like a conference room's worth of people
and yet look at the impact they had
worldwide
that impact has included concrete
changes to how films are now made
intimacy coordinators we did this for a
long time before that was a thing and
it's still sort of shocking to look back
and think that that was never in place
before it just seems like such an
obvious need on a film set I think also
you're starting to see the way that it's
coming into screenwriting the way that
you know female characters are being
written there's definitely there's a big
shift from
you know gorgeous girl in bikini
beautiful but she doesn't know it you
know they're seeing you're seeing
markedly less of that which I think is
very welcome it's time to write Harvey
Weinstein might have fancied a film of
his life would one day be made but it's
doubtful he imagined this script we're
all here Harvey how have you talked to
this real life this Reckoning this
Legacy Katie Spencer Sky News